- I'm a 31 year old virgin, hello.
(light music)
- I lost my virginity
when I was 23 years old.
- I lost my virginity when I was 26.
- I've thought about it constantly
probably since the age of 12.
- In my mind I was like
we're gonna kiss a bunch.
It was mostly the kissing part
that got me really excited.
- It's gonna be in some
bathtub with candles.
- Well I grew up on romance novels
and I loved the happy ending.
- We're both shredded and we look amazing.
- But the way those scenes are described,
there's never any pain
and the guy is always huge
and you're like okay.
- I waited til I was older
because I was a committed Mormon.
- I was raised by a conservative mother
who was also a realist,
so in the same breath
she would say, "Wait to have
sex, wait until you're married.
"But if you want to have sex, let me know.
"We'll put you on the pill,"
which is very convoluted
for a 14 year old to understand.
- Mormons aren't supposed to
have sex outside of marriage
and they're definitely
not supposed to have
the kind of sex that I wanted to have,
which was sex with other guys.
- When I was 13 years old a cousin of mine
that I really looked up
to on my 13th birthday
she pulled me aside and
she said, "Hey Eileen,
"last night I lost my
virginity to my boyfriend.
"When you are ready you have to make sure
"that you love them and
that they love you back."
- I waited til marriage to have sex
and that's just something I believed in.
I want to give myself to my wife
spiritually, emotionally, physically.
- My mom had just died in
February like three months
before that and I had never
gotten the mom/daughter
conversation that you have about sex.
Just took it's place
so it became my Bible.
- I have a lot of fears about my body
and someone seeing me
at my most vulnerable.
- My coworker.
We were both students at
the time at universities.
- I met my wife at church.
- And we had become really good friends.
- And it took two years for me to finally,
my eyes to open, this woman is beautiful.
Why have I never tried to date her?
We dated a year and then got married.
- I got really drunk on my 23rd birthday
and I went to a bar with
another cousin of mine.
This guy was there and
him and I had had this
make out in a car relationship.
Every now and then we would get together
and make out and that kind of was it.
- It finally happened
when we went camping.
We both lost our virginity at
the same time to each other.
- Wedding night, it was
December 31st, New Year's Eve.
The best way that I've ever
brought in a New Year's.
- Two virgins trying to
figure out how to do it
and how to make it work.
- It was sort of what I
expected because I knew
it was gonna not be great.
- I leaned over to him and was like,
"Hey, I'm taking you home tonight."
- The next morning we were
staying at the same house
and I came downstairs as he was
having breakfast and I said,
"I just want you to know that
what happened last night,
"I remember it and I liked it very much."
And then he got this big
smile on his face and he said,
"I liked it, too,"
and he eventually became
my first boyfriend.
- It was a really sweet morning after.
There was a lot of high
fives and orange juice.
- It was bad, it was real bad.
And the next day I was
sore but I felt like,
okay well, day number three of being 23.
- I had a really good experience overall,
but also I do regret that
I don't have those years
where I could have been
active and enjoying sex.
- I'm very happy that I waited.
- I'm glad I waited but at the same time
the fact that I just kinda let it go
to this fucking douche
made me feel a little like
man, you should have given
yourself a little bit
more respect and know yourself
a little better than that.
- I don't regret being
a 31 year old virgin.
The dream scenario at 31 would be that
I start dating a guy that I like.
- I think the number one thing
that I can see really clearly
looking back is to trust yourself.
Most times you know when you are ready
and to trust that feeling.
- You want to wait, wait.
But if you want to bang,
fucking bang, dude.
- When you do have sex
you're gonna realize
oh, I had this huge buildup for no reason.
I feel the same after,
I'm the same person after.
It doesn't change my identity.
Don't let other people
put pressure on you.
- The best thing I could tell you,
which I try to tell
myself every day is that
you are enough, you are loved,
and your virginity does not define you.